everybody welcome to lab coding with
Jesse I'm Jesse and I'm so glad to be
back after it's been a while I think the
last time I streamed was the 19th of
July so if you don't know I had surgery
on my wrist and I will spare you the
sight of my my scars for my surgery I
just got my stitches out this morning
and so it's been a little rough trying
to type my wrist is finally getting to
the point where it's strong enough that
I could tight for a while so doctor said
probably like six weeks before it's
actually starts to feel better than it
did before the surgery and probably
won't be like really feeling back back
to normal for about three months so I'm
just gonna take it easy not lift lift
heavy weights or anything like that but
you know typing should be okay I was
able to do some work from home so I'm
gonna catch you up on what I've done and
then we'll get to it and we'll start
working on this the search component
that we worked on a while ago and then
we just kind of left it there because we
needed some work with the data before we
could really finish it so we finally got
that work done now we're gonna go back
and finish it so hey everyone see a lot
of people saying hi Julia
so glad that you could make it to to a
stream so that's awesome
Phoenix hey I guess I'm just gonna say
hi to everybody
all right cool so for those of you who
are new this is how it goes
after I do a little explanation of
what's been done since the last stream
we're gonna do a 25-minute Pomodoro
session of coding and then I'll take a
five-minute break and answer all your
questions will do another 25-minute
Pomodoro session of coding and then
after that we'll just do a question and
answer session where I'll answer all
your questions until there are no
more so if you do have a question and it
seems like I'm ignoring you
I am but just for 25 minutes and then
I'll answer you okay so let me let me
think what I've done all right so here's
some stuff that may be important for you
to know if you are actively working on
this project locally I upgraded a lot of
things a lot of packages so I've
upgraded next I've upgraded react I've
upgraded material UI so you definitely
need to run yarn or npm install if
you're going to pull this down if you've
already had it because a lot of things
have changed I've been working mainly
with I guess the menus right so the side
menu if you notice has all new
navigation and almost all of the links
work now there's some that I just don't
have content for yet but that that's
pretty much sorted out now that took a
while I've also moved I've got a little
bit more organized I went back to using
the Trello board so let me know if
anybody's interested in and having a
link to the Trello board to see where
we're at and what still needs done in
the project I can definitely share that
I took care of some of the issues on
github and I also added a few more
issues so if you're interested in
helping out a contributing check out the
issues there there may be some new ones
that you know you you may be interested
in helping with okay that's that's an
okay summary I'm sure I'm forgetting a
lot of things but of course you can all
check out the commit log on github if
you really want to know you know
specifically what's changed let me get
my face off the screen here and look at
some code all right I'm gonna start my
Pomodoro timer and I'm also gonna start
what do we have
and grok let me make sure I have this
yeah have the dev server server running
let's start n Gras
I'm about to paste this link in the live
chat if you click on this link or copy
and paste it in your browser you will be
able to see the website and it will
update as I'm changing it locally so
you'll be able to click around go to any
page that you want inspect it with your
own dev tools it kind of makes it a
little bit more interactive than just me
coding and in you watching okay so let's
go to this search page I haven't had
been able to do any coding yet this
morning I've been doing mostly paperwork
since I had this is the first day back
in the office since the 19th so I'm late
on some of my paperwork let's see okay
so here's the search page let me make
this a bit bigger also not sure if any
of you are from or around Salt Lake City
Utah but I'm gonna be there for react
rally is it next week
it can't be next week that'd be I think
it is though alright so I think next
week I'm gonna leave I think the 13th my
flight goes out so I'll be in Salt Lake
City for a couple days so let me know if
if you're there if you're in the area if
you want to hang out or something and
then I'll be in New York right after
that so if anybody is I'll be staying in
Brooklyn for a couple days so let me
know if anybody's in that area wants to
hang out you know we try to get together
have some coffee do some coding or
whatever okay I don't need this right
now so let's kind of move that over and
make some room let me know if this font
needs to be even bigger okay so here's
what's going on in this component so you
can see we've already done quite a lot
with this just to break it down we're
using the WordPress API
to get data from WordPress which we're
using as our content management system
and this search base let me show you the
the front-end how this looks so I don't
have a link to it so you need to
manually type in search so at the end of
that end Rock link that i typed in if
you do slash search you'll come to the
search page alright and this is just a
live search so so as you type it will
pop up with the results it should it's
actually going quite slow so I may have
to think about some way to fix that I
think because we've added so many
different post types but if you remember
how it was before now there's a lot more
information different post types that
are now showing up in the search and
then we have this sorting but we also
have these filters and these are the
ones that we put in a while ago so you
see we can filter and just get you know
what we want here
so we need to add a lot more filters now
that we have a lot more content types
right so that's what we're gonna do I
want to try to accomplish that now
there's still a few other things I'd
like to do with this page but the
primary thing now are getting these
filters in there okay so here's what's
happened so far we have I've added in
some things into state our initial state
under these check boxes but then I
thought hmmm
sorry about that I've been trying to
hold back a yawn for a couple of minutes
now my sleep schedule has been all
messed up since I've been off so I
didn't get that much sleep last night so
what I was thinking is instead of
manually entering a lot of these
different types in here you know maybe
we could do something programmatically
so I down at the bottom of this
component we can see all the different
post types that we have now so I don't
think we need to filter by all of these
post types some of them are things that
it's not really likely that somebody
would even filter by that but a lot of
these will become filters okay so I
think I have two check boxes in the
state to create the form controller so I
think what we're gonna do is actually
let's look at this are these the only
ones I want to have now let's try it out
on here so we already have Department
major and faculty that are check boxes
but what I'd like to do is instead of
just having these let's say manually put
in which I'll scroll down a second to
show you what I mean by that I'd like to
just map over these and create the check
box elements out of that so let's scroll
down and find that I really want to
refactor this it's too big it's not
necessary right now just need to get it
to work first and then we can refactor
all right where's uh here's our filters
so you can see we have these form
control labels so right now I have three
form control labels here so it's it's
hard coded but I think what we could do
what makes a lot more sense is just map
over the the check box
labels that the names that we have in
state and then we'll have them all in
there later on if we want to add more it
will make it easier it'll cut down on
the overall size of this component so
that's the that's the plan for now I
just happened to glance over and I at
the live chat and no beer says a long
time do you remember yeah for sure I
remember so how's it going over here
thanks for joining us
okay so here's what we're gonna do we're
gonna say this state it's going to
JavaScript land first if you're in react
and you put these little curly braces
here then you can write JavaScript
inside of those curly braces so we're
gonna do map oops this state checkboxes
dot map okay so map is gonna kind of
like a loop right it's going to loop
over everything and let us do stuff
inside of there so we get to when we use
a map the the first word that we're
gonna put the first string or variable
let's say that we're gonna put in here
is basically anything we want it to be
but that's gonna be the name for each
item okay that I maps over so in this
case I you know what I think I'll just
put item a thing about putting checkbox
but that's kind of long I like item
better here and we're gonna use an arrow
function okay and that arrow function
when we use that it's going to
automatically return whatever is in
there so you don't need to actually
write the word return and have it have
it go in there
okay so now we have the form control
label and we need to use this item to
get what we need
so states so we want to keep that this
state but it's gonna be actually we know
we may have this maybe a little bit more
tricky than I thought let me see
yeah we're gonna need to do it like this
yeah so let's just copy this for now so
I'll explain this in a second I'm glad I
caught that earlier okay so here's what
you really need to do so you do to
object entries this state checkboxes and
we're going to map over them here okay
and then we're going to get the key and
the value
okay that's gonna allow us to so the
first way I believe what was going to
happen is we were just going to get a
bunch of falses as our initial values we
weren't going to get the actual name
that we wanted for the checkboxes in
this case we're going to get the name so
the key is going to be the name so let's
let's get rid of this stuff okay
all right so we have our form controller
let me hit save so we get
what does it sound cheap Rob so mad
because I don't have a key
all right let's give it a key so our key
in this case is just going to be key
okay and then all right these are just
the indentation things right yeah all
right now we could say for checked so we
need to check to see if this check box
is supposed to be checked and these are
I can't believe just slip my mind
controlled components
I believe that's called let me know if
you know what I'm trying to say and I'm
saying it wrong but I believe it's
controlled components
basically what the value of this check
box is determined by the state so when
you click the check box it doesn't
immediately cause a check what it does
is it changes state and then a state
change triggers re-render of the react
component and when that rerender happens
this check box this value for checked it
goes to state to see whether it should
be checked or not whether it should be
true or false okay then that's when the
the check box will actually get checked
or not so from a user's perspective
nothing changes but in the background it
definitely is a different flow all right
so I'm wondering if
now let's just let's keep it like this
so I think this will work
once I really sure but let's try it
he whoops I'll see if that works and
then on change this handle change and we
need to pass it the the name here so
we're going to say key and for value
we're also gonna say key and then for
our label we're gonna say key and we'll
use a CSS to make that capitalized for
now it's just gonna be all lowercase
just like it is in state okay now we can
remove these two form form control
labels and oops I think I deleted a form
group yep I did okay let me know if you
have any questions about that I seems
like I went through kind of fast and
there is quite a bit to this component
if you've never seen it before so just
let me know and I can definitely go back
over it a little bit more slowly and
let's see trailing spaces
all right for whatever reason my Auto
formatting indentation is not fixing
this those red lines are just for
indentation so hey cool look at that so
our checkboxes are there now for our
filters let's see if it actually does
anything though so first of all I'm just
going to check for an error when we want
to use the checkboxes cool so check out
console it's warning me about a key for
up here let me remove this first let's
refresh this may have been old warnings
all right cool so we don't really have
those warnings those are old so we have
fixed that
hmm area okay so it seems like this is
going a little bit slow okay all right
but that part works so that's cool that
was actually the most complicated part
of what I wanted to do today let me
check my time oh yeah we're good at
plenty of time let's clean this up then
with a little bit of CSS and we just
need to have this capitalized so we can
test it out right now should be what is
it text oops
text transform capitalize there we go
yep that's it
okay yeah so let's go ahead put a text
transform capitalize on these and we can
do it right here on the well actually
let's see if we could do it on here
these components are material UI
components I'm assuming that it'll just
pass that style prop on down but I'm not
exactly sure and the reason I'm going to
do this in line is because it's only one
thing we're adding on there usually I
don't like to put a like make a whole
nother class for one thing and react
it's actually I mean it's arguable here
but it's somewhat easier to read if you
see the whole component here with the in
line style and you can you can do it but
if it starts are going to be two three
four and line styles that's way too much
it clutters things up and in that case
we would end up putting it down here
with the rest of our style C so we can
add you know a lot of them and it's not
really a huge deal in terms of clutter
okay so in this case we'll do text
transform and we'll say capitalize
all right I'm assuming I spelled that
right we'll find out in a second
yeah all right cool
Department made your factory isn't it
awesome all right so this is basically
our search page right now I'm not like a
hundred percent thrilled with the way
this looks it looks super plain so any
ideas you all have to make this page
look a little bit nicer I'm definitely
open for that I do want to talk I guess
for a second about why this is so slow
and see if any of you all have any ideas
for how we can make this faster so it
was way faster originally and here's
what I think happened so let's go up to
our search string so we're adding on to
the end of this string like all these
different post types right so we
actually have to say I want to search
each individual post type like we can't
just do a search for all of them at once
the API doesn't allow that so this is
how I had to do it so what that ends up
creating hope leus was shown and that
word
she's the that should be
trying to get this there we got one of
those two faculty no I don't want that
right now let me refresh so we we get
rid of a lot of this there we go
all right look how long this is I'm
gonna copy this area all right let me
copy this and just throw it in here in
wow I have so much stuff all right so
look at this look how long this is look
at how many different post types it has
to go through and I'm talking about on
the WordPress side of things with the
API it has to go through all of this so
I think that's what's slowing it down so
if anybody is knows about PHP databases
WordPress and has any ideas of how we
can make this faster let me know let me
share with you one idea that I have so
from what I've heard okay from other
people that do kind of really advanced
things with WordPress the folder
structure in the WordPress database it's
a my sequel database so sorry I don't
mean that the table structure is not as
efficient as it could be so potentially
what's possible and I know people have
done this is to change the structure to
make it work more efficiently
I'd really would not like to get into
doing that but that's maybe one possible
solution to basically customize the the
database for this type of thing for
search right I don't know let me know if
anybody has ever even heard of that
being done or what you think I know
there is a plugin that was shared with
me certainly if you did that Christian
may have shared
I don't know if he's here right now in
the stream but I believe he shared it on
one of the issues and in the github repo
I think so I'll have to go back through
and find it so we may be able to use a
wordpress plugin to do this and not have
to like manually manipulate the database
so I think the speed is just it's a
problem it's it should definitely not be
that slow all right let me check it time
like five minutes all right to know
about five minutes I'm going to go to
the live chat and answer all your
questions so hang in there if you have
if you have questions oh wait a second
Rohan says cache the output of the
WordPress API and say that server-side
okay actually I kind of like that idea
all right let's think about that idea
also I just saw Jeff said there's a
graphic you'll plug in we are using the
graph QL plug-in but unfortunately the
graph QL plug-in does not support search
like this so that's why we had to use
the API so basically for the rest of
this app we are using graph QL and then
for the search we're using the WordPress
API we may have to use it in some other
places too which we'll probably get into
that in a different stream all right
let's let's clean this up just a bit
while we're waiting for the the timer to
go off here I mean we can potentially
try to save a little bit of time with
this debounce I mean if we drop this
debounce down to 300 milliseconds it
could save us some time I don't think
it's good I don't think that's the
problem though it's not it's not the
debounce it's a problem let's make down
so see
yeah it's still not
does that even change it okay that was a
little bit better
you know what we also probably should do
is put in loading indicator I mean
that's it it would at least indicate to
the user that something's happening so
let's let's check that out do we have
loading somewhere else we do where else
are using loading I think on some of the
pages so the timer's going off right now
when we come back we'll probably end up
doing is adding in some sort of loading
indicator because regardless of whether
we get the speed thing fixed it's still
a good idea all right
let's do five minute break so I'm not
sure what kind of music y'all are into
but there's a really good eighties
playlist I've been listening to on
Spotify it's called all-out 80s so if
you enjoyed in the 80s check that out
right now that's what I'm listening to
you right now okay I'm gonna scroll all
the way up to the top and work my way
down and get through as much as I can in
these five minutes probably won't get to
everything because there's a lot but
just hang in there and then after the
next pummelo recession I'll go through
everything yeah so alright yes some
people asking if I'm okay
so yeah my wrist is okay the surgery was
successful is just gonna take me a while
to get fully recovered so for now it
actually feels worse than it did before
the surgery but I'm hoping it will get
better the thing that kind of stinks is
like I was finally getting back into
exercise and lifting and now like I
won't be able to lift anything heavy so
I won't be getting swole anytime soon
okay an AK says can someone point me to
the best way to learn Python please okay
I personally don't know Python I've used
it a little bit I know the Udacity intro
to computer science course it does use
Python so that might be a decent way to
get into Python because you would learn
Python at the same time that you would
learn computer science principles so I
would check that out of here if you like
the Udacity style of course you can do
it for free so that's the only resource
that I know that I've used and learned a
bit of Python from
brotherman Britt says what programming
language do I learn to start off okay
well I personally would recommend
JavaScript I really like JavaScript I
think it's useful for so many different
things because you can you can pretty
much make anything with JavaScript there
they're not a lot of other programming
language is where you could easily do
that so I would recommend JavaScript
even to get started with it you can run
it in your dev tools console so you
don't even need anything special you
don't need to load anything on your
machine so that's what I'd recommend but
if you have something you really want to
do and another language is better suited
to that then maybe try that out okay so
if you're really into I don't listen
machine learning Python seems to be
where it's at right now with machine
learning so maybe you want to learn
Python first so there's not really going
to be a one-size-fits-all answer to that
question but I can at least give you
what what my answer would be for you
know what what I think is good it may
not work for you though let's see
yes says how to design a suggestion box
and Daedalus I don't know how to answer
if you want to you can DM me on Twitter
or something - and we could talk more
like specifically about your particular
case that Brown says I'm working on the
HTML cat photos I'm new to coding need
some help okay so I'm assuming that's
the free code camp cat photos things so
again Browns if you want you can DME and
I'll try to help up full stop says hi
from Nepal hey how's it going thanks for
joining us
Blake says glad you're back I'm glad I'm
happy to be back I missed your Anna says
loved to contribute if I can Oh awesome
and if you want more details on like
what I need feel free to check out the
issues on github leave comments there to
get more details if you want you could
DM me like definitely happy to if you
would like to contribute I'm I'm happy
to help with that Nimisha says hi from
India I'm really sorry if I'm
mispronouncing your name but house would
go on there in India thanks for watching
Robert says can you teach us MATLAB
program please I don't I don't know
anything about MATLAB so I'm not going
to be the person that you want to teach
you that if anybody in the chat now or
even watching later you could put in the
comments if you're in a MATLAB and
interested in helping out with that or
if you know of any good tutorials you
know please let us know Rashid says hi
Jesse from Indonesia hey how's it going
what time is it in Indonesia right now
I'm not sure what time zone that is but
it's got to be late right I mean yeah
it's got to be close to midnight over
there
Yeah right anyway okay I didn't get
through everything but I got pretty far
I'm gonna write down where I left off at
cuz there's a lot going on in the chat
today and I don't want to be able to get
back to my place here okay
all right so I'm gonna get back to the
chat I know I didn't get through
everything so just hang in there for a
little bit longer if for some reason you
can't stick around to hear my answer
I'll still answer your question you can
always watch the the recording of this
video later on okay all right one more
Pomodoro session let's try to get a
little loading indicator and to speed
this up I'm gonna check out another page
where we are you already using a loading
indicator and try to maybe take that
code and see if we can use it maybe
modify a little bit that'll be a good
start so do we have it on it not on
index page judge is there we go oh I see
what we're doing
okay so we're using graph QL in this
case and it says if the result is
loading hmm sorry about all these yawns
then we just do the loading indicator
okay
okay I don't know that we're going to be
able to just take this so it's that's
not a big deal though let's let's do our
own thing
okay so here's what we need to do
okay so we have this fetch search term
so what if we did we could put something
in state alright let's add in the state
loading and this would be SB you know
true or false for loading so we'll set
it to false by default okay and what we
can do here then is say let me see if
there's somewhere better to put this I
don't think there is but I think it's
worth a shot
okay alright so the first thing we'll do
here when we go to fetch a search term
with this set state and it'll say
loading loading true it's about right
away as soon as it starts the search
will set loading to true and then then
here
see if we can this at state data data
and then although loading false I think
I can do that we'll see it's not worth
looking it up at this point I think it's
worth just saving it and seeing what
happens actually let's let's put in
something down here that'll actually
show up so that we can get a nice visual
so the container I wanted to go below
all right so this is what it'll be here
it'll say loading oops this states
loading so this state loading and let's
just put will just do just like we did
in the other thing looting
okay all right so what this will do is
check for this state loading if this
state loading is true then it'll go to N
and it'll check what's here and in that
case it'll actually render this but if
this state loading is false it'll just
stop there and it won't even check the
end because this statement will have
failed immediately right see if it works
okay so no immediate I want to see the
console here
let's clear that console out and we'll
try to search nice okay let's see if we
get the same thing here okay cool
so we do have that loading that pops up
and it stays here I mean that does look
a little bit weird
but I think that I mean that's not bad I
don't know what's up with me today so
for everything I've tried has worked
it's just it's amazing it's never
happens
okay all right well that works for now
it would be kind of cool to have a nicer
looking loader so let's just let's check
out material UI just to see if AB a
loader I don't think they do the last
time I checked they didn't but maybe
they've got something with an update so
you're loading indicate what is this
Oh progress blur nice that's cool they
have them now all right what do you
think I really like these circular
things but let's check out some of the
other things just to be sure the linear
indicators are kind of cool
hmm
alright let me know what you think I'm
gonna give everybody 30 seconds to let
me know whether you want the circle
loader or the linear progress it's a
progress bar right progress indicators
so let me know circular or linear I'm
gonna look at the code for it while I'm
waiting I'm gonna estimate 30 seconds so
I'm not really gonna count to 30
I'm starting to get some oh okay well
linear linear linear linear circuit is
too common do the linear michael says
circular if the Lund years often cost
for station I thought that too but we
could do the indeterminate linear so
that the you know there they won't so
the linear determinant would indicate
that like we're actually gonna get
results when it hits the end and I don't
want to mess with that I mean that would
kind of be cool but I don't want to mess
with that but we could do this
indeterminate so it's just saying like
hey something's gonna happen we're not
telling you in though alright so it
seems overwhelming that we're gonna go
linear indeterminate so that's cool I I
was surprised by that I was leaning more
towards the circle but let's go with the
linear indeterminate so we've never used
one of these before in any of the
projects so this will be cool so first
of all let's grab this and import this
linear let me make this bigger a little
bit bigger so we're gonna import linear
progress let's go all the way up here
there's so many imports on this page and
then I can't wait till we can refactor
that number mats
there we go okay now we don't even oh
cool we don't even need to add any the
the styles we can just grab this linear
progress and that's nice
this is super simple wow this is even
easier than the circular so we're gonna
pray replace this h1 loading with our
linear progress save that and see how it
looks
nice
oh I like that I like that what do y'all
think
Wow that I really like that
that's cool honestly that I don't know
if it how it felt to you but to me it
felt like the load times were actually
faster I don't think they were faster it
wouldn't make any sense we didn't do
anything but just that that indication
seemed like it went faster to me so
that's that's really cool I didn't know
I mean to click on that but let's see if
this page actually works to be good and
it did not
since
hmm
all right so evidently our news face
doesn't work yeah nothing you know I had
somebody working on this I thought they
got through all of them but maybe they
didn't but I'm not getting into air or
anything let's see how much time I have
13 minutes okay cool
actually this is a good opportunity to
show you a little bit of how the
wordpress side looks on this so let me
there we go let me go on here make this
a bit bigger so here's the wordpress you
see we have a ton of custom post types
happening here if you want to see how we
did that
check out the repository for the fus
wordpress plugin it's in the same github
organization as the repository for this
project is links in the description
let's go into or yet news I can find it
I really need to alphabetize these there
we are things just grow sometimes you
know you have a short list you can find
everything and then you just keep adding
a little by little and eventually
without even realizing it's it's a mess
and it started finding it so what was
that news counting students
see we can find this yeah there we go
hmm okay so this obviously has continent
let's check the slug so what should
happen is based on that slug it should
be able to find this this information so
accounting students to assist local
residents with accidents accounting
students to assist local residents with
taxes
yeah it should work right news good
students hmm
okay so I don't think it's a problem
with the way these were done in
WordPress this looks looks good so I
mean I know we're going kind of off off
the topic of what I set out for this
dream but if you don't mind let's check
out what's going on with our graph QL
queries for the for the news pages so go
to news real quick and let's see we're
doing where's our query so we're using
Apollo to help us with our our graph QL
stuff and we're using page query and
then we're passing it the name okay so
let's go to our page query there's all
our graph QL queries page page we're
type
did we not pass a type I don't think we
passed the type you're okay we're not
passing a type that's why I didn't work
okay let's let's figure out a place
where we are passing a tight area
no wait we are we are to the query what
am I thinking we are passing a type oh
no that's the page go back to news no we
definitely are my fault I don't know why
I didn't see that
okay so we're passing a type to the page
query we're passing the ID
let me check this data for secondary
you've got too much stuff one
I wonder if
I wonder if any of this is is messing it
up I did have an issue at some point
where depending on if if one of these
were found it would just basically not
doing anything would freeze up
let's check our check our stuff in here
accounting sues justice local residents
okay yeah that's definitely it's
definitely the right stuff I mean make
try to make this bigger for you so we
can directly look at what our state and
props are at any given point here with
our reactive tools so that's what we're
doing right now just to get an idea of
where where the problem lies like if
we're getting the data back and it is
stored in props then we know that the
issue is kind of like after that point
so this will help narrow it down for us
okay there's our ID
okay cool here's our query where name
equals accounting students
let's see did we get alright cool so
we're getting we have this content so we
have it all right we have the content we
have the title okay
all right so let's actually I want to
take this title out we don't need that
in here I want to leave this it's double
check
okay we're putting the content in there
so our content data edges no consonants
all right so we've got the data the
problem I guess is somewhere in here
I'm gonna check the live chat in case
you are seeing something that I am NOT
I just see we had a comment from who
here though I'm probably mess your name
up I'm really sorry let me know how to
pronounce it and I'll say it right the
next time but anyway the comment says I
like you so it just caught my eye there
Thanks
thanks for watching I appreciate the
government alright alright let's try to
do instead of content let's maybe
directly do let's try this
let's go with div and let's see what
we're getting and I want to just say
data
area okay little sloppy here but okay so
we go we are getting this data it's
under news edges node news edges node
title okay all right let's make sure
we're doing that right okay so under
data should have news this site okay I
see what's happening
do we need that
so if the data already yeah we will have
to say news what's the type though that
we're getting let's go back to to this I
want to see what the type is okay the
type is a news and this says a news all
right so that should work so you should
be able to get data with this drop stage
let's just verify that that would work
all right that did work I'm just gonna
go down the chain here and see what
we're messing up edges zero yep that
works edges zero one let's just do it
node node and this good title there we
go yep that should be there why is the
title on isn't it anyway
okay all right so that's working
maybe it's because we're going
dangerously set innerhtml
yeah let's switch this up
hmm
that's a little weird how they're
organizing that but okay so something's
happening with this
the straight title
all right that's really weird but if we
do this
so weird alright so evidently something
I'm doing here is it's messing this up
probably because I'm doing it like this
and I bet this works now yep that works
all right here's the problem I apologies
if you notice this and we're trying to
tell me in the chat and I didn't see it
but I don't I have no idea why I didn't
see this I wasn't actually creating like
these direct variables right so I'd
probably just copy and pasted this
result you know this conch data and I
left the the brackets around it right
but I wasn't trying to get like an
object right this I wanted to be an
object I didn't want these to be objects
but I was that's what I was making them
so anyway that was the problem so I
don't know I tried to be systematic
about finding that error and that's
usually a good way to go you'll find it
in this case if I would have just jumped
in and just took a look at the code
maybe I would have saw that and changed
it I don't know but anyway that works
now my timer did go off but let's commit
some of this and get it up to get up
that way y'all can check it out
let me alright let's see my my node want
has been doing weird stuff where it just
keeps refreshing all the time and it
won't let me run my tests so we'll see
if it does that we may have to just kind
of manually start the server just for
the test but for now let's do a git
status as soon as I push this up to get
up I'm gonna go back to the questions
and answer all your questions alright
cool so these are the only two pages
that we did work with so that's good
first let's do a git commit and we're
gonna commit the search page loops pages
search
I'm sorry what am I thinking I need to
do it get ad there we are I'm going to
do yarn CM okay because we have it set
up to help us out making our commit
messages otherwise you could just do a
git commit and then add your message so
let's add a new feature and we'll say
add checkboxes let's say filter and what
LC Oh loader a loading indicator and I
don't think we had any that attach to an
issue so I'm just gonna skip that okay
so hopefully all the tests run I can
start answering questions now while we
let these tests are on if they'll pass
then we'll move on and make the next
commit I'll push those up to get up and
then everything we've done today will be
available to you all on the github repo
so let me scroll back up to where I left
off in the chat
oh cool those all passed let's get let's
add the news page now yeah and we're
gonna say this is definitely gonna be a
fix
[Music]
so say 6c
dispense the ISP you spelled displace
hey Ron this place yeah that's it
isn't it weird out just simple words
sometimes like you know you spelled them
a million times but all of a sudden you
just you forget anyway content now
displays properly okay
oh man Phil Collins just playing right
now I'm on Spotify in the air tonight
it's my favorite Phil Collins song if
you see my head moving like if that's
why all right cool
that's ready we'll do a get push and
it'll all be up to github great okay so
where were we
okay an access how long of a time
usually does it take the average person
to learn Python
I really have no idea and I haven't
learned Python myself and really it it
definitely depends on like your your
natural ability like how much knowledge
you have coming into it and then how
much time you have to dedicate you know
each day to learning it so that's that's
going to be a question that even for
yourself will be hard to answer you know
and you'd know better than anybody which
your capabilities are manju says how to
start learn coding or other programming
yeah it kind of depends on your
preference for how you learn let's
assume you're going to start with
JavaScript okay if you wanted to start
with JavaScript you could try out the
free code camp curriculum that'd be a
great way just keep doing those
exercises if you prefer that like video
learning style you could try out
something like Udacity and do some of
their free courses they come with a lot
of videos if you wanted to just do
videos no exercises you could certainly
go on youtube and watch like buh buh
Karns has a whole video series on the
free code camp YouTube about learning
JavaScript you could check that out if
you like to read you can get the
eloquent JavaScript book or the you
don't know J S series those are both
available for free to read online or you
can get the the print copies if that's
what you like so those would be my
to get started
all right michael says why not
programmatically build the filter list
from the the hits after you get the
search results like only add the topics
that show up oh that's interesting okay
I'm have to think about that hmm
yeah that would kind of be a nice
feature I don't know that that's
something that is necessary to get in
before we launch but I do like that yeah
I really like that that's a good idea
oh by the way the launch date I mean
obviously launch day it keeps getting
pushed back for this thing I still need
to have a meeting with some people from
another department to get the okay for
this to launch that meeting had to get
pushed back now I'd like twice it's just
hard to get all those people together
and then because of my surgery we had to
push it back so I believe the meeting
now is set for the end of August so I'm
thinking there's no way the site's gonna
launch until at the earliest the very
end of August maybe beginning of
September so we'll be working on it for
a little while but I mean that's not bad
we have more time to make it look the
way we want to optimize it you know add
more features so I I kind of really want
to launch it I've been wanting to launch
it for a while but just can't I just I
gotta wait for approval so that's where
we're at in terms of launch
Oh Sean asked what are we doing here
today I assumed I was Sean that you
figured it out at this point because you
asked that quite a while ago so I'm vaga
to go over it again
okay ocean said it's a controlled
component alright so when I was trying
to say I don't even remember what I said
if I said it right or not but when we're
talking about our inputs in particular
checkboxes there was a controlled
component when I was mentioning that
when you click it it doesn't actually
directly change the check state of the
checkbox what it does is it changes the
states in react in your component and
then the checked attribute of that
checkbox is getting its value from state
and the the update is triggered any time
there's a react state change
Julie asked to forget a playlist for
these yeah yeah for sure so if you check
out the free code camp playlist you'll
see I have several playlists now so
there's one main playlist that has all
the videos I've ever done in the live
coding with Jessie series and that's
huge so I don't know if that's for
everybody but this project has its own
playlist and it's project five so if you
check out the project 5 playlist it's
just for this project this is stream 90
of that playlist so there's quite a lot
here so it'd be kind of crazy to have
watch everything at this point I
definitely recommend worth watching on
like to time speed I think you can
definitely understand me still a two
times feed just slow it down is there
something interesting I guess and maybe
like skip around it to some of the
videos over there topics that you're
interested in I mean unless you really
have a lot of time to kill and want to
watch them all but it's it's a lot of
time at this point no Bo says it's not
really tutorials it's like group work in
public yeah yeah yeah yeah it's true I
know these aren't exactly tutorials
because I don't like go through
systematically and try to teach
something but I hope that we all learn
something though I definitely learn
stuff from you all the time
Christian Brown says don't forget
shoutouts oh okay
actually let me do that let's go to get
up repo for a second get up I know I
probably have this github repo open in 3
other places right now but what I'm not
signed into github are you serious
that's crazy
I haven't had to sign into forever and
now I have to do my authentication
all right let's see get Oh No don't you
hate when the phone Authenticator
changes right in the middle are you
trying to put the code in okay so what I
want to do is give shoutouts to those
you that actually did submit pull
requests recently so let's go here okay
so Christopher brown has several pull
requests so let's see the green keeper
stuff is a bot that automatically sends
pull requests when packages need updated
so yes so Chris added these title
elements to things so this is for
accessibility purposes so thank you for
that Chris let's see the faculty also
this get faculty graph key to return a
purple response
y'all can check out the details of these
of course if you want I mean this is a
public repo Daniel and I'm not sure with
the dates I'm getting kind of back a
little bit more so yeah these are older
ones I think we've already gone over but
anyway and then just to show you all
since I haven't done this for a while
here's all the contributors to the
project so thank you everyone who's
contributed if you're interested in
contributing just check out the issues
you know let me know which one you're
interested in so obviously me Nikki
Harshit Chris are bought SDA Blandy
elbow I know I wish I like could
remember everybody's real names as
opposed to their github names but
Michael so there we are lots of
contributors so far 12 contributors of
which only one is not really a person so
really awesome thank you
Julia said I loved it thank you I
appreciate that
Roland said some SVG art assuming you're
talking about sgv art for the for the
progress indicator if that's the case
actually I love SVG art I just don't
really know how to do it I haven't spent
time trying to do it but to have like a
custom SVG loader the loading indicator
would be super cool
Oshin says what plug-in is that on the
wordpress side sending you json data
actually the the rest api for wordpress
is built into WordPress core now so you
don't need a plug-in anymore to get
multiple posts though you need to get
the the multiple post plug-in let's see
which one that one is let's go to our
plugins so we have the WP REST API v2
multiple post types plug-in okay so
that's going to allow you to put in
search for multiple post types in one
API request
rod huh says hi hey how's it going
thanks for watching
Marino says what what did you had that
was bad in your wrist I had some torn
like a torn ligament they needed
repaired as soon as says what is your
recommended best way to style reacts
style components standard CSS I use a
variety of things to be honest with you
I'm not sure which one I like best so
I'm still trying out I'm trying things
out you know and I'm open to trying to
find the best way so I haven't decided
yet which one I like the best 5 vibe
Huff says say something interesting
about progressive web apps ok alright so
for any of you don't know what
progressive web apps are I guess I'll
just explain really briefly so they're
usually abbreviated PWA but a
progressive web app would be like a web
app that could potentially work offline
so everything that would be needed for
that could be stored like in a
serviceworker so the serviceworker is a
special javascript file that sits in the
in the browser in between your website
and your server and it can intercept
Network requests so potentially if you
had everything you need to run your app
in your serviceworker the requests would
go to the serviceworker which still
lives right there in the browser
serviceworker would send back the
response and it would never have to
leave the browser or go to the server so
if there was no internet it could still
work so if you've ever used anything
online that still works offline it's
probably done using that type of service
workers I'm thinking things like like
Google Docs you can still use Google
Docs even if you don't have an internet
connection in your browser right so and
we call it a progressive web app because
you can't have everything there right
depending on what your app is without
connections so what would happen is like
your base app functionality would work
without a connection
and then it would progressively get more
functional as you had a better better
connection so that's what we mean by
progressive web apps so that's kind of
the way to go now so if you can build
your site and as a progressive web app
then you probably should what we're
building right now will work as a
progressive web app aster says why do
people use typescript with graph QL do
you I don't use typescript with graph QL
I recently saw a video about Peggy
raises Cameron boy last name is but she
works on the Apollo team and she was
talking about using typescript with
graph QL and so I assume like it's
something that's encouraged by like
Apollo and I'm not 100% sure what the
benefits of doing it that way are I just
I haven't used typescript that much at
all I can definitely see value in it but
for the stuff that I've been doing it
just hasn't really been a big deal to
try to use typescript so if anybody else
knows better like why what advantage
there would be to using typescript with
graph QL please let us know Aster's is
how did you learn graph QL not only just
reading documentation tutorials and
things really harsh it one of the
viewers that that contributes a lot to
projects really wanted to use graph QL
and started using it with Apollo and he
did a lot of you know in terms of pull
requests and I would look through what
he was doing and try to understand what
he was going so I learned a lot that way
just by reading his code and then
editing it like taking what he did and
then applying it to a different
component and so that's that's I kind of
really learned like hands-on you know
and there's still so much I don't know
about it
I was just watching a tutorial on it
this morning
our tge 34 says if I wanted to be a UX
designer what degree would you recommend
I don't really know for a design degree
hmm I touch you I'm not sure I don't
know what like what it would be called
you know and different schools would
would probably have different degrees
available so and that seems like a job
you may not even need a degree for so
sorry I can't answer that better but
maybe it's just slip in my mind but yeah
I don't know
sergey serb says does he even read
comments on youtube I do try to read the
comments I know I'm behind on the on the
comments but I do I think I try to go
back when I get a chance and try to look
and see with who's who commented and so
I do apologize if I've missed a comment
aster says how many react projects do
you recommend a junior dev have before
applying at least one I would say and
then after that apply Reigate this is a
similar question that I get is how do
you know when you're ready to apply for
jobs and I would say you're ready to
have a job whenever you can convince
somebody that you're ready right you go
into that that interview if you get an
interview and you convince somebody that
you are you are ready you can bring
value to their organization alright you
can do good work and then if you if you
can convince them and get the job then
you are def right that's so there's no
magic number right obviously more
projects are going to see more
impressive but that's also really kind
of it depends like what kind of projects
are they whether the quality of them the
complexity so you can't really give a
number
that t0 t0 says does coding and being a
programmer make you socially isolated
actually not at all it's been the
opposite for me hmm Wow
so time I didn't have any G fuel today
that's the problem let's blame it on
that yeah so it's been the opposite for
me I've actually through programming
I've met people from all over the world
and talked to them and I'd never be able
to do that if I had I don't know let's
say a different kind of job where I
would just you know go into my normal
work and I just interact with the people
around me this has kind of opened things
up to just so many more people right no
not everybody's gonna have that right
like I do the show
I'm common somewhat active on Twitter
and Instagram with other programmers I
go to conferences so you kind of have to
put in a little bit of effort so you can
definitely do this job and be isolated
right let's say you're a freelancer you
don't work with anybody and you sit at
your house yeah you could be isolated
but it depends on how you want to you
want to do it right so I think it's it's
easier to be isolated in this job than
in some other jobs but it doesn't have
to be like that nobody says what if you
change the structure like all the post
type tabs horizontal after the search
bar and also have all the post types
search tabs user will manually search
and it will reduce website bandwidth and
I think it would quite fast but all the
post types and the tabs you can add
loading yeah you know beer that's
actually that's not a bad idea I'm gonna
think about that yeah I'll think about
that
Stephen says what's going on I sent you
a paycheck created using some JavaScript
to navigate floorplans models and pop up
let me know what you think okay cool
I'll check that out yeah thanks for for
sending that over
see Phoenix says today I made my first
pull request on get up alright
congratulations that's awesome let's see
what was the what was the pull request
okay I see farther down it's a design
based pull request for the free code
camp Top Contributors badge Oh awesome
awesome awesome Oh way to sing it did I
tell you all about the stickers that we
have now let me show you okay so if you
follow me on instagram you've probably
seen this already but let's see if we
can get this let me change the camera
and show you this so Phoenix says design
a sticker so we have this live coding
with Jesse sticker now so I have like I
think a hundred of them I mean - a
couple that are on my laptop's but my
stickers now so I'm not sure the best
way to get these stickers out to people
who want them I mean postage for these
stickers will cost I mean just depends
on where you're at I guess so I don't
know I mean for sure like if anybody
really wants one mailed to me and you
like just send me you know a dollar or
something for postage I can send one out
I'll probably take them around with me
wherever I go to conferences or meetups
or anything - so if you all have any
better ideas for what I should do with
these stickers let me know
see
okay we got a question about the font
it's um feet fiery font
Fira
and let's see a lien anonymous says I
love the DMX and Phil Collins song but
the original is good too oh wait I don't
think I've ever heard that one how did I
not hear about that I'll have to check
that out
haha Julia put my misspelling of
displays so she she definitely caught me
attempting to spelled this place with an
IES at the end yeah spelling is not my
strong suit like I definitely like I
check everything that I put out there
before I hit Send
especially on tweets because my spelling
is terrible I cashed his best language
to learn for beginners alright so we
actually had that question earlier on so
I'm not going to go through a big thing
about it but I personally recommend
JavaScript if you want to know why watch
the replay of this video and go back I
don't know about a half hour before what
I'm this point and I answer that kind of
an in-depth work
Omar asks where to learn react and
master it you can start out with some of
the free code camp stuff to learn react
code Academy has a react course Udacity
has a paid react course that's good so I
would recommend those places if you can
and then there's react training it's
pretty good as well
I've I've done like a little bit of
their coursework I don't think I've ever
gotten through an entire course not
because it wasn't good just because I
kind of got busy and forgot about it but
those places are good also the react
documentation is great so if you can
check out the documentation and just
read a little bit every day that would
be good too and then work on projects
that keep practicing and trying to do
you know try to expand to do more things
with reacts you know every every day if
you can
Roland said SVG is easy with Illustrator
or Adobe XD
I can do some if you've got some ideas
on what you need okay I don't know I'll
have to think about that I don't have
any ideas right now but yeah let me
think about it
Julius says in response to where to
learn reacted master at watch all his
lashing videos haha yeah that's quite a
lot let me think
yes so did Project five itself now has
ninety videos so and that's project five
right so we've been through a lot this
is definitely the longest project but I
mean we've got to be approaching 200
videos now right and each one of those
is at least an hour long sometimes
longer so I mean we're talking like
maybe 300 hours of content I don't know
maybe more it's a lot so anyway you
don't definitely don't you will not be a
master to react even if you do watch all
my videos I don't I'm not a master
myself but you may you may find
something helpful
oh okay Julie have some good advice
about the we had a question earlier
about what degrees should I get if I
want to be a UX designer Julius's don't
worry about the degree mentor under a UX
designer that's a great idea
I've been hearing more about this like
idea of mentoring I think I listen to a
podcast about this recently I can't
remember which podcast it was the they
sent this idea of the master and
apprentice in InDesign in programming
and I actually really like that ideas
you know you have this kind of master
apprentice and then it evolves into kind
of like a mentor mentee relationship I
think that's that's a great way to do it
I kind of wish I've had various kind of
like mentors before but never someone
like that was clearly like I was
apprentice to and I think that would
have helped me to get better faster
avoid a lot of mistakes so I I really
like that idea
shut chat Jana says hey hey how's it
going sorry if I messed up your name
please let me know let's see
ambition says Monday and already waiting
for Friday I don't know I mean I've been
I haven't been doing that much work the
last couple weeks because of my wrist
thing so I'm ready to do some work I'm
not ready for Friday yet Julius says for
your next project you should create a
forum for coders actually I'm another
Julia I don't know if you saw anything
about the JavaScript AF project so I
bought the domain name JavaScript AF and
yeah it's kind of a side project we've
been working on it and one of the things
that we want to have is something like a
forum so we have we have some features
already ready so I believe if you do go
to JavaScript AF you can see it I'm
gonna go to it on my my other screen
here to see if it's up you know what
it's not working right now
I wonder if all right so we don't have
it up right now
too bad hearts just not watching but
anyway we have project that's like kind
of like that so we'll see I definitely
need to do an update because we I
haven't done an update on that project
for a while aster says do you understand
JavaScript closures call apply blind
methods I can understand closures when I
need to and I read about them but it's
not like like if somebody asked me an
interview question right now about it
I'd probably be a mess right so yeah
that's things like that
usually I look at a lot of programming
stuff like there are concepts in
programming that you know you don't
always you're not always able to just
explain right but when you have to use
them for project you can do them because
you'll most likely look that look it up
right there's so much that you don't
just wing it you know you look it up
first so sometimes I think like coding
interviews are a bit I don't want to say
unfair but it's just not realistic to be
able to just rattle off like definitions
of things like that because it's it's
not what we do right we we get an idea
and we make it happen by looking at
what's already been done building on
that and stuff so anyway if I were like
going to go on an interview I'd probably
be studying up on all that stuff so I
would have answers cuz I mean that's
just the way it works with interviews
but yeah for now I have you asked me
that question I'd look it up and I would
say you know what I know exactly where
to find the answer and you can find it
here and that would that would really be
my answer
even if I was doing an interview right
now that's what I would say Anna says I
cloned the repository but don't know how
to start it in the browser I used to
work with create react app and NPM run
only do I need to install web pack or
something you should be able to run well
make sure sorry if you've already done
this I'm just I'm trying to go over the
basics okay so I'm not assuming that you
don't know this already but for anybody
that wants to do the repo I believe
there are some instructions in the
readme or the contributing MD file but
in case it doesn't cover this you know
clone the repo locally maybe like if you
want to fork it first and then clone it
and then you want to do a you want to
run yarn or an NPM install depending on
which one you use make sure everything
gets installed and then just start it up
you want to run NPM run dev or yarn dev
that's going to get everything started
and then it should work from there so
those steps should get you started if
that's not working for you let me know
see in walks a c-sharp developer or Jas
developer I'm a JavaScript developer we
have done a bit of c-sharp on this
stream before because we were working
with some legacy code but we don't
really have to work with it anymore
Julius says the mentor-mentee
relationship is how I learned
programming I dropped out of university
yeah for sure
I really think if somebody wants to be a
programmer my take on it is you should
only go to university if you have
scholarships that are paying for it or
let's say like your parents are going to
pay for it otherwise it just doesn't
make sense financially because it's
unnecessary to get a job as a programmer
you'll put yourself in a lot of debt
basically for something that's not going
to really give you a return right the
amount you can make as a self-taught
programmer versus the amount you can
make as a programmer with the degree is
not there's not that much difference
right there potentially could be no
difference at all right depending on how
good you get in what your connections
are so you know not only are you taking
extra time in like four years or more
but you're spending all this money and
you're not gonna get a return so it's
just it doesn't make sense financially
right if we were analyzing this as like
an investment opportunity it would make
any sense right so it only makes sense
really if you're getting your education
paid for by somebody and then you know I
think about going for it but only if I
didn't already have to pay for stuff
like you know if I already had a family
or something I bills to pay like even if
they're paying for my college I wouldn't
do it right because I need to be able to
make money I could learn the same a lot
of the same stuff I've learned in
college by actually doing projects and
getting paid for it and learning while
I'm doing so anyway and I work in
universities so I mean I fully
understand the benefits of a university
but in this particular field it's it's
just not necessary
hey harsh sincere harsh it um I have a
question do we have JavaScript AF
running anywhere like the dead version
of it I just tried to go to JavaScript
AF in it it wasn't up and running so
hello okay I see it's cut it's down
because your card expired or something
because it's needs a five dollar fee to
be up where it is all right what account
is that that we're running that on and
it just if you want hard [ __ ] if you can
DM me the info or something I'll get
that up and running again
let's see
almost the end there live chat here so
if you have any questions get them in
now cuz we'll probably end pretty soon
here are [ __ ] says by the way I'm on
holiday just saw your story in Instagram
and I had a look okay well enjoy enjoy
your holiday are [ __ ] I don't want to
don't worry about JavaScript AF I don't
know what you have to do any work just
enjoy your stuff and yeah have a good
time also good to see you good to talk
to you I haven't haven't talked to you
for a while
okay so and I just saw your message that
you saw the yarn install your on dev
thing okay cool yeah let me know how it
goes and feel free to you know DM me on
Twitter or Instagram or whatever to if
if you have questions Renee says
sometimes depending on where you live it
may be required to have a degree you
know that's a really good point that's a
good point so I'm speaking generally
from the perspective of somebody living
in the United States so I don't know
what the situation is in other countries
so yeah so take what I'm saying and
maybe just apply it to your situation
right so I shouldn't make blanket
statements like that your your country
it may be different maybe a degree would
be more important to trying to get in so
here in the United States right now the
way things are going you don't really
need a degree but like I said if you can
get a degree without going into a lot of
debt it's it's not a bad idea right you
never know how things are gonna be ten
years from now right
it's things could change right maybe
people want a degree maybe you never
know you never know what could happen so
I just personally think in in the United
States right now it costs so much money
that it's just it's too much it's just
too much debt
my my young says I'm new here how's it
going thanks thanks for watching we're
kind of wrapping things up here but feel
free to catch the recording and you ask
any questions if you want phoenixes do
you have any ideas for a Big Data
project uh yeah actually I do have some
ideas I'm just not sure where to get all
the data I need but I have some ideas so
yeah maybe we could talk about that
though I Phoenix is I'm unable to decide
on one I need to make one for my final
year project I don't know if anybody has
any ideas for Phoenix let us know
oh okay Harsha's saying it's in the
open-source plan but you still need $5
to keep it up okay because we're using
the custom URL right I'll do that you
know what I I cancelled I dropped us
down to a lower plan I think not
realizing that it would totally shut it
off
as I said if you are 18 and thinking
about what you are doing with your life
in terms of employment what a I scare
you
me no I mean I'm not I'm not scared of a
I'm really hopeful for the opportunities
for a and I would be my outlook
basically is like okay I may take over a
lot of jobs but you still need somebody
to make the AI right you need I mean
there are a lot of people that are super
hopeful about what AI can do but the
terms of like the general artificial
intelligence like based on what I've
heard from people who are actually doing
the work for AI not just like fans of AI
we're not close to that we're nowhere
near close to that so it's going to be a
long time before we actually have like
AI that doesn't need people involved at
all so my my thought process would be
okay well I'm not going to try to get
one of those jobs that's likely to be
taken over I want to be one of the
people that's guiding it so and if I was
eighteen that you know I'd be in shape
to say alright I'm gonna try to get into
like one of the top test tech schools
like here in the United States maybe
like Carnegie Mellon in Pittsburgh or
maybe like MIT or something that's what
I would shoot for I try to get in there
and try to do a lot of work now that I'm
married I have kids and stuff
responsibilities I can't I can't do that
right so I'm the one I'm doing I really
like what I'm doing but yes if any of
you are younger and they're thinking
about it that's the route I would take
and you know you you can make a huge
impact on the world
with that kind of stuff it's uber says
what's the best books to learn design
patterns oh man
I I can't
nothing's coming to mind right now like
I vaguely remember there being something
about design patterns some book but I
can't remember it right now I'm sorry
sam says react fibre what are your
thoughts I think it's awesome I mean
from what I've seen I don't know well
like the technical stuff about it but
it's it's gonna make things faster right
and that's always good
Harshit says still need to train models
and tensorflow for the AI to work yeah
you're right I mean I don't think people
who don't like know about the process of
how you get AI working don't realize how
much human input is actually needed to
guide this stuff right and and how
narrow the field is right so I mean
there's a lot of cool things AI can do
but it's not at like the sci-fi movie
level at all yet and it's in my mind
like I'm not even sure we can get to
that level realistically and if we can
it's going to take a really long time
like I'm not trying to be a pessimist or
downer about it but just like based on
what I know about the technology it's
it's not it's not simple to get a
general general artificial intelligence
even from a hardware side of things like
that much computing power it's going to
be insane and then from a software like
programming point there's it's also an
immense amount of work that's going to
happen have to happen in an immense
amount of data that would be needed
oh yeah that's right hard [ __ ] good so
react fiber is already out it's in react
sixteen so so react fiber is is there
okay Laura said are you asking about
suspense
yes suspense is not out yet and it seems
amazing
check out damn it it's a Dan Abramov I
think its DNA or most talk on react like
suspense when did he give it it was this
past year I can't remember what
conference he gave it at but check it
out it's amazing alright so that's the
end of the chat and yeah we've been one
almost two hours now so I think it's a
good place to kind of wrap things up so
thank you all so much for watching
hopefully you found this useful thanks
for all the interaction in the chat this
is awesome
and I'm gonna try to stream a little bit
more oh good news I am I think I'm gonna
be getting a new computer a new PC for
free which I should be able to use to
make it basically make it
I can stream from home I don't know if
y'all so the last time I tried to stream
from home but the it was terrible like
the quality was terrible so I think what
I'm gonna be able to do is route the
actual streaming through this PC to free
up all the computing power on my macbook
for just programming and I think that
should solve the issue so once I get
that computer in and I get it all
configured I think I should be able to
stream better streams from home and I'll
be more consistent with it because right
now it's like it's just really easy for
me to say I don't feel like the one at
today the quality is probably not gonna
be good anyway and I don't write so I
want to get back to streaming like more
regularly
so anyway that's coming I just don't
know when I'm gonna get the laptop but
hopefully sometime soon all right yeah
so thank you all again and yeah so
hopefully I can stream tomorrow but
we'll see I'll be home tomorrow so so
until next time have a great day